but I do gangster
this week we getting hedonistic with the
Picture of Dorian Gray by Oscar Wilde up
in 19th century London an artist named
basil just finished his masterpiece a
portrait of some fine-looking stud named
Dorian Greg his boy Lord Henry be all
like damn that boy is fine when Dorian
roles in the peep game at his painting
Lord Henry start preaching to Dorian
about how a pretty boy like him ain't
gonna stay pretty forever so we got to
drop being all virtuous and chase them
pleasures of the flesh why he's still
got it doing it seems like he did so he
takes his portrait home and start
chillin with Lord Henry on the red a
month later Dorian tells Lord age that
he got himself a new Dane some actress
named Sybil and like that door you want
to put a ring on it it's all good till
one night Dorian taste his boys to see
Sybil shaking onstage but she be
straight trippin Sybil so bad that
Dorian be all like a girl but Sybil says
she's so in love with his fine ass that
she don't care about acting no mo but
Dorian ain't dealing with no husbands
and dumps her ass right then and there
Dorian comes home and notices that his
portrait changed somehow and now we got
a nasty sneer all about his mother what
word comes that Sybil done I stir stuff
Dorian decide he don't give up no more
and gonna lock that porch it upstairs
and devote himself to lusted living mmm
years passed and word on the street is
that even though Dorian still young and
fine he'd been up to some scandalous one
day he was in the basil who say that a
lot of us be talking mess about his rep
basil say is it for real then Dorian
takes basil back to his crib where he
lets the painting do the talking and
that thing Oh
jacked up now Dorian gets so riled up at
the thought of his ruined image then he
grabs a knife and shanks Bassam
that fool did later Dorian hits up Lord
Henry and tell him that he'd done with
honor he
mystic God but Lord Harry just think he
playing and don't pay him no mind the
Dorian goes up to the portrait to see if
it's changed now that he want to be
righteous but that ugly-ass mug this
nasty of the never after hearing the big
ass thump Dorian servants Rob upstairs
when they see a wrinkly ass corpse and a
portrait of young Dorian looking all
fine ain't that a [ __ ]
go back before this story dropped in the
1890s Wilde was beefing with his tight
ass publishers who weren't digging on a
steamy bro on bro action it wasn't until
2011 that the uncensored typescript hit
the streets why these haters gotta hate
man cuz I'm a real most homey say wow
just laying down a morality tale see
during his mine always worn between two
philosophies I've either live in the
wall life I'm saying man that mess and
chase autumn human temptations since
Basil's always getting his tidies all
bunched up over dorias purity he reppin
the moral side whereas harry's dirty
self reppin the wild side of humanity
that only care about intensity of
feeling to Harry
Dorian ain't nothing more than a choice
piece of meat as Dorian keeps sinking
into Henry's whack-ass hedonism the
portrait gets fugly and fugly
like it's his soul telling to eat him up
and chose the wrong path that's one of
the reasons his hiding spot bothers him
so much every moment of his lonely
childhood came back to him as he looked
round you remember the stainless purity
of his boyish life and it seemed
horrible to him that it was here that
the fatal portrait was to be hidden away
but what Dorian don't see is that
nothing simple it's good and evil it
ain't just his vices that he trying to
hide from the world it's also a part of
himself like wild himself said all
excess as well as long Annunciation
brings its own punishment truth is if
you trying to say that life is all about
purity or sin or the body and the soul
then you spray trippin cuz what's really
[ __ ] up during his gang is that he
thinks he's got to choose one or the
other
fool needs to realize that a real player
embraces all those things like doing you
say each of us has heaven and hell in
them hey thanks for checking me out
make sure you embrace your inner thug
and press subscribe peace
you
[Music]